after three months of being locked up in
Romania Andrew Tate finally got released
from prison so we're here in beautiful
Miami to ask the common person what they
think about Andrew Tate being back so
I'm sure you guys heard Andrew Tate got
freed from prison today what are your
thoughts I mean he should probably go
back why should he go back I mean your
guess is as good as mine everybody's
guess is as good as mine what's your
guess I mean he's a piece of [__] what
has he done that you don't like
everything like can you name something a
misogynist uh puts down women he what do
you think misogyny is like I'm curious
better than women
are men better than men
and when you know we're on a ship and
it's thinking the men have to stay and
die on the ship and the women get to
leave it's like I T12 I feel for you
that's the if we go to war we're still
going it must be so wrong with this
footage
I actually like haven't I don't I don't
really have an opinion I don't know he
got really I don't even know why he got
arrested like if I'm being fully honest
it's all good at least you're pretty oh
thank you Andrew Tate got released from
prison today so what are your thoughts
he should go back to prison you don't
like him he's a sex trafficker accused
but there was no proof sex trafficker
all right if there's no proof isn't that
a there's no proof though I'm talking
about all right
damn bro they get so rattled and they
don't know why there's no proof you
think that these people would at least
want some evidence to back their claims
but they're so brainwashed by the media
words pop up on their phone and that's
their thoughts people don't have
original thoughts anymore your phone
says something and that's that's your
brain now it's crazy funny coincidence
we just ran into Leia hell Prince
parents
so what are your thoughts on Andrew take
getting released from prison today I
think
I think the guy was there and he
shouldn't
he shouldn't no I totally agree I mean
what was it all about you know he was
put into prison there wasn't a trial I
think in my logic you go to prison once
you're convicted of something but he
wasn't convicted of anything so you know
what ow fantastic what are your thoughts
he should go back yeah yeah you guys
don't like him
why not because it's just
it's
just you know why you don't like them
because he's um
I think it happened much sooner than I
was expecting I'm glad that the judge
did the right thing what I want
everybody watching this video is to do
shout out to you for moving with speed
you're actually following change advice
speed speed remember everybody who was
celebrating remember everybody who was
lying remember everybody who was
insisting that they are guilty that they
are terrible people and just pay
attention moving forward and see how
they react see how they try to shift
their narrative see if they start to
pretend to be on the take side I think
these past three months lose a pivotal
time to pay attention four months to pay
attention to the influencers who stood
by like you and like a lot of the people
in our Circle every single day saying
free top G doing these podcasts thank
you so much Nico I really appreciate it
I'm sure you've heard but Andrew take
got released from prison today what are
your thoughts fantastic bro we've all
been waiting for this and I think it's
like one of the most tremendous things
what's one of your favorite messages
that Andrew Tates taught you uh how he
says that uh only nerds have Teslas and
that top G is the type of guy if he sees
you and your [__] and Tesla he'll grab
you by the neck and rip you out the
[__] Tesla in front of your [__] I
truly respect type G even though I'm in
the disgusting category because I'm a
fat [__] I hope I could curse yo truth
is all these women in society have
[__] for leaders they have people like
Kim Kardashian who are [__] thoughts
uh making sex tapes for fame and then
when a guy has a man who's masculine
that leads him to something prosperous
that teaches him how to hustle and grind
and be a man we got shunned bro you got
people like Tristan and Andrew who get
put in jail but reality is man like all
these women are led by thoughts but a
man can have a masculine figure nowadays
it's crazy you're beautiful you must
like him uh I have no idea Andrew Tate
is balding right no he's not never use
that video
it's all good but what do you think of
Andrew Tate do you like him or not um
there's no proof of that though there's
no proof it was all accusations he just
got released today because they didn't
have it tight fan I like Andrew Tate
yeah why did you like him he spreads a
really positive message for young men
discipline a strong body's a strong mind
his business advice is really good he
actually teaches you how to treat women
very well do I seem like a rude guy in
any way like I would do anything bad
something like a real guy but the fact
that you like entertain is giving a red
flag is it a red flag to like pay for
everything and think it's my duty to
protect and provide for the girl that
I'm with I feel like if you really care
for someone that should be a given that
shouldn't be something like you but
that's kind of that's his whole message
thing no his whole message is like
profiting off of women Andrew Tate is
making money off of like a bunch of
young dudes who believe in him Andrew
Tate is using you guys don't believe in
him he's making your life more ruined
you seem like a nice guy you seem like
your mom is proud of you like I don't
think you should you should follow him
yeah I mean I I don't follow the part
about him doing only fans management but
his message other than that is generally
pretty positive I feel like you should
be confident in yourself and you should
treat like someone however you want to
treat them when you're like really like
a girl you should treat them like you
want to treat I'll treat you right don't
worry thank you my love it was great
what was your name
I'm sure you heard today Andrew take got
freed from prison what are your thoughts
dude [__] listen Bro [__] Society dog
you know what dude is society wiping
your ass no no like I'm not even trying
to be funny like this is something I
tell everybody
you're all good dude this is something I
tell people all the time bro like when
people think that their opinion matters
about me I go let me ask you two
questions number one do you pay my bills
number two do you wipe my ass obviously
they don't wipe my ass because that's my
job you know but like so I'm sure you
guys heard but Andrew Tate got released
from prison today you guys like them I
love Andrew Tate what do you think on
Andrew Tate big fan have a comment no
comment I'm a big fan I don't really
know him I don't really know I don't
know that's a good answer yeah that's
true too I'm gonna okay I'm gonna run it
back no no why do you like him well I
like some of the things that I've seen
him say I really like and I agree with
some of them I don't but a lot of them I
like what he says I do that's awesome
yeah I said that it's a good point that
you made because a lot of people don't
know him and they just go right to
hating him and they don't even know why
weird I don't know why like you don't
even know this guy and you have
something like good things to say he
really does he has some like powerful
things to say to men
you know I'd push back but come on not
everyone you don't agree with everyone
yeah you can't agree with 100 with any
anybody it's always the beautiful women
I like him
there you go look at him flirting W risk
final message for tape
um Andrew Mr Andrew if you see this I
just want you to know that you were
jailed unfairly even if people have
opinions about you I just think you were
jailed unfairly if no one put forth
evidence you shouldn't be in jail that's
just how the justice system should work
so I'm happy you're free I hope you're
fully expunged and you're very handsome
man so I hope you have a good day
interrupt top G how has your
relationships with women been since
your Andrew Tate experience my
relationship with women has actually
gotten so much better since I started
following him because I'm just more of a
gentleman I recognize that you never
want to be pushy not even in a sexual
way but like I just invited a girl down
to Miami to come spend the night in
Airbnb and she was like I have work I
was like all right good like that's fine
like I'm not gonna beg her you don't you
want to be like your own guy you want to
be the Big G and she wants to come along
that's totally fine she can come aboard
your train you know in so many different
ways I'm so proud of you sonny keep it
up you're the best maybe we'll get
married in another life
Andrew Tate just got released from
prison what are your thoughts I hope he
dies
you hope he dies why don't you like him
let's let's be for real right now let's
let's be for real like why don't you
like them he's just a piece of [__] what
has he done he's misogynistic as [__]
what do you think misogyny is how do you
be misogynistic to women and they treat
women like objects how did he do that
like is there something he said that you
didn't agree with there's a bunch of
[__] you said like can you name
something not right now you're putting
me on the spot I'm nervous my heart's
being a little fast right now okay it's
all good at least you're pretty don't
worry about it I think if I tell you
something really quick so I actually
have a counter argument
um no no no just give me a second we
heard you look
these men how to be more masculine all
right well listen we have to hear you so
you're gonna hear me he's not a
misogynist lady okay [__] you too okay
he's not a massage
you're a freaking misogynist
these guys huh
oh she's calling my voice
not even true if you're talking [__]
about top G you gotta go back to school
my boy Andrew Tate got released from
prison today what are your thoughts oh
she's already gone yeah honestly why why
don't you like them
look
what the
[__] interesting bro keep it pushing
stupid
hey Ain't No [__] bro I'm a man
now come here come here come here I'm a
real [__] though right this guy the
[__] was that about dude be careful
brother [__] shoot listen bro I got a
[__] AK-47 down my dick right now dog
I'm ready to shoot blanks
all right look bro I'm sorry but you
could cut that out the video let's chill
out of it no bro you don't got to worry
about it bro I know but I don't want to
be I got your back bro trust me look
nothing's gonna happen I'm from the
streets bro I promise you like I know it
sounds like stupid but I'm actually from
the streets bro born and raised I know
how to talk to certain people you got to
talk a certain way it's a vocabulary man
nothing's gonna happen I give you my
word bro right now I'm a shake on it
what is that the black capillary yeah so
look brother there's two types of speech
there's regular speech like hey how's it
going but then there's Street talk like
yo you straight what's up with it bro
you know things like that like that's
how you speak a certain way so I know
how to dude I've been homeless for so
long bro I've been in the streets of Los
Angeles New York City Miami and the
hoods Road
trust me bro I know when things are good
you're good but I promise thank you bro
you're good man
if anything happens you can have my
camera look I'll shake on that too right
now I'm all good bro I don't need your
camera I don't know but I'm putting it
just to show you bro you're in good
hands where I promise you nothing's
gonna happen all right [__] straight
up dude I'm sorry look bro I'm conscious
[__]
[Music]
so we just asked everyone in Miami what
their final thoughts are on Andrew take
getting released we had a collab here
with with fat G ended up popping into
the video becoming a pretty big part fat
G I'm sorry I'm a pretty controversial
person when I speak and I tend to piss
people off I have no foul intention man
it's all love but unfortunately we live
in a society we have to speak to people
a certain way thank you fetchy no
problem man
so we probably got security guard trying
to call the capsule I got this no
worries
[Music]